Turkey's biggest city Istanbul saw
thousands of demonstrators demand the
release of women imprisoned in Syria the
organizers say that more than 13 and a
half thousand women have been jailed
there since the Civil War began almost
eight years ago and that more than 7,000
of them have been subject to torture
rape or other inhumane treatment no DW
correspondent Julia Hahn is in Istanbul
close to the famous attacks in square
where the main women's March is taking
place welcome
Yulia what's been happening well right
I'm in the city centre and we had to
move a little further away from the
crowd we've witnessed some quite heated
scenes just recently the police has been
trying to disperse the crowd right in
the back I'm not sure whether you can
see that there is a huge police a
blockade policemen are and women are
heavily armed
today so you're just seeing a small part
of the crowd of the actual crowd that we
saw today people women were actually
trying to walk down March Town Istiklal
Avenue a really meaningful place but as
I mentioned they were blocked by police
so they were basically gathering for one
or two hours hundreds of people
definitely maybe thousands it's really
hard to guess from looking at the scenes
here last year women were still allowed
to march down Istiqlal this year as I
said the police intervened and called
people now to disperse and that's
basically what we see right now people
are trying to leave the city centre
through the three side streets
okay so police who have dispersed it but
they allowed this mass gathering to
start in the first place and mass
protests have been banned there in
Turkey since that the coup in 2016 why
did they allow today's to go ahead well
first of all it's of course they're
internationals women stay
it's a meaningful protest but as you
rightly said especially since the failed
school here in Turkey in summer 2016 we
have witnessed a massive crackdown on
media organizations civil society
organizations on private persons as well
we have been criticizing the Turkish
government or president out on himself
so all kinds of demonstrations be it
workers unions demonstrations the Gay
Pride they have all been banned so that
shows how difficult it has become for
many people to voice their concerns that
their anger how little space there is
left and I think today tonight is just
another example and that's why actually
Women's Day is so important for many
people here not just for women but for
many others as well
Yulia Hahn in Istanbul thank you